hey guys my name is Jess it is the 11th
of August and you're watching gamespot
knees set approach red has confirmed the
release date for the witcher 3 game of
the year edition the game of the year
edition is due to arrive on august 30
and the developer have released a brand
new trailer you can check out in full on
gamespot in some regions the game will
be called the complete edition and
across the board it'll be arriving with
all previously released dlc the goatee
edition will be 50 bucks on ps4 xbox one
and pc earlier today amazon posted a
product page for the complete edition
that made mention of the release date
and price point which said a project
went on to confirm next up destiny to
art may have leaked and here's the
details even though Destiny's next
expansion rise of iron is arriving first
in September destiny too appears to be
well and truly on the rumor radar reddit
user Dustin baxton discovered that
destiny artist is these does matter who
worked on the taken king posted art to
behance which he described as being from
destiny to see images appeared to be
from a trailer as they all share a
similar aesthetic and several appear to
be video frames and given their
similarity the images show off a number
of swords and shields which don't
immediately bring destiny to mind but
later images depicted the traveler and a
to the artist page is now gone but
because the internet is what it is all
images up for your viewing pleasure
finally quantum break drama is the thing
that's happening as remedy has said they
don't intend to update the Windows Store
version remedy head of communications
Thomas pure hell wrote on Twitter that
it's unlikely remedy will be releasing
another windows 10 patch despite
reported issues with quantum break that
appears to suggest the most up-to-date
version will be the steam version to
rise in September when asked whether
remedy plan to offer a free steam key or
a discount to quantum break fans who
bought the game on the Windows Store and
now wanted on Steam you are applied we
don't make those business decisions we
make the game so they games but the
stories on titanfall 2 and SpaceX
mankind divided and come back
again tomorrow for the top five stories
of the whole week I'll see you then